สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
วันอาทิตย์ก็ได้นะ
วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
21:00 นค่ะ
3 ทุ่ม 49 ลืมเขียนตรงนี้นะคะสามทุ่มสี่
สิบเก้านาทีก็เป็นเวลากลางคืนนะคะตอนกลาง
คืน
ก็วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหมคะวัน
ที่ 2 แล้วก็เดือนเมษายนแล้วเดือนเมษายน
ที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อนมากๆนะคะนักเรียน
ดวงอาทิตย์
ใหญ่มากค่ะจะซัก 38 องศาเซลเซียสนะคะร้อน
คนไทยเนี่ยแบบว่าไม่ชอบเดือนเมษายน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ชอบที่มันร้อนแต่ก็ชอบ
เดือนเมษายนนะ
อ้าวครูหญิงไม่ชอบร้อนแต่ผู้หญิงชอบเดือน
เมษายนทำไม
ก็เดือนเมษายนเนี่ยมีวันที่ 13 วันที่ 14
แล้วก็วันที่ 15 เมษายน
เป็นวันหยุดไม่ต้องไปออฟฟิศไม่ต้องไปโรง
เรียนแล้วได้หยุด 3 วันติดกันก็เลยชอบ
เดือนเมษายนค่ะ
ครูหญิงชอบเดือนเมษายนเพราะผู้หญิงเบรค
นี่เองนะคะ
ผู้หญิงไม่ทำงาน
ถูกต้องค่ะครูฟ้าอาทิตย์หน้าใช่ไหมคะวัน
จันทร์ตั้งแต่วันจันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์เนี่ย
วันที่ 10  10  11  12  13  14 ใช่ไหม
หรือเปล่าวันที่ 10 เนาะเอ่อถึงวันที่ 14
เมษายนเนี่ยครูหญิงเบรคไม่ทำงาน 1
อาทิตย์ค่ะครูฟ้าดีมาก
บ๊ายบายออฟฟิศ
ใช่แล้วผู้หญิงจะทำอะไรคะผู้หญิงจะนอนหรอ
คะ
ไม่นอนค่ะผู้หญิงจะไปเที่ยวค่ะครูฟ้า
ไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ทุกวันครูหญิงก็อยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหมแล้วก็
นอนๆๆเนี่ยไม่เอาแล้วผู้หญิงจะไปเที่ยว
อันนี้ประเทศไทย
อยู่ที่นี่เนาะกรุงเทพฯนะคะ
ที่นี่คือกรุงเทพฯผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะไปเที่ยว
ที่
อีสาน
จะไปเที่ยว
ภาคอีสานแล้วกันตรงนี้เนาะนี่คือภาคอีสาน
ของประเทศไทยมีผู้หญิงจะไปเที่ยว
ไปเที่ยวอีสานเลยหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงจะไปถ่ายรูปไปเที่ยวไปกินอาหารหรอ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าเวลาที่ไปเที่ยวเนี่ยครูหญิง
เนี่ยไม่มีบ้านนะที่ที่นี่นะบ้านเนี่ยผู้
หญิงไม่มีบ้านไม่มีอพาร์ทเม้นท์ไม่มี
คอนโดมิเนียมเวลาที่เราไปเที่ยวเนี่ยเรา
ก็ต้องหาโรงแรมสำหรับนอนใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเราจะนอนในรถไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
คะนักเรียน
ไปค่ะถ้ารถเนี่ย
ครูหญิงขับรถไง
ค่ะนอนในรถไม่ได้ค่ะ
เราก็ต้องหาโรงแรมใช่ไหมเนี่ยหาโรงแรม
โรงแรมก็อาจจะโรงแรม 1 ดาวโรงแรม 2 ดาว
โรงแรม 3 ดาวโรงแรม 4 ดาว
โรงแรม 5 ดาว
มีไหม
โรงแรมที่มีดาว 1  2  3  4  5  6 มีไหมคะ
นักเรียนโรงแรม 6 ดาวถ้ามีนักเรียน
comment บอกด้วยนะคะครูหญิงไม่รู้เหมือน
กันเพราะว่าโรงแรม 5 ดาวเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็
ไม่เคยนอนมันแพงโรงแรม 5 ดาวเนี่ยถ้าเรา
นอน 1 คืนที่ประเทศไทยเนาะก็น่าจะประมาณ
10,000 บาทไหมครูฟ้า
ที่ไทยนะคะนักเรียนที่ไทยนะ 5 ดาวซึ่งถ้า
เป็นยุโรปอเมริกา 5 ดาวอาจจะแบบ
50,000 ก็ได้อาจจะแพงมากกว่าอันนี้ก็ไม่
รู้นะคะ
เราก็นอนโรงแรมซักผู้หญิงคิดว่าประมาณ 3
ดาว 4 ดาวก็โอเคนะ
โรงแรม 1 ดาวโอเคหรอคะโอเคไหมคะครูฟ้าผู้
หญิงไม่โอเคนะคะกลัวว่าเวลานอนโรงแรมแล้ว
เนี่ยมีประตูประตูล็อคไม่โอเคมีคนเดิน
เข้ามาเอาไม่เอาอันนี้ไม่เอานะคะ 1 ดาวก็
ไม่นะถ้าเราไปเที่ยวแล้วเราก็อยากจะนอน
หลับอย่างมีความสุขนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นโรงแรม 3 ดาว
สีดาวก็โอเคแล้วใช่ไหมใช่ผู้หญิง
[เพลง]
ก็จ่ายอีกนิดหน่อย 3 ดาวดีกว่านะคะจริงๆ 5
ดาวก็ดีแหละค่ะแต่ 5 ดาวเนี่ยมันแพงไงถ้า
เราไปเที่ยวเนี่ยถ้าคืนนี้คูณ 5
หมื่นบาทใช่ไหมมันก็แพงเวลาที่เราจะนอน
โรงแรมเนี่ยบางครั้งเราก็ไม่ได้เราอาจจะ
ไม่ได้เลือดแค่ว่าเป็นโรงแรมกี่ดาวก็ได้
นะเพราะว่าเวลาครูหญิงจะนอนโรงแรมเนี่ยนะ
คะโรงแรม 3 ดาว 4 ดาวหรือ 5 ดาวเนี่ยก็
โอเคแต่ที่ผู้หญิงจะเลือกแล้วก็คิดว่า
สำคัญมากๆถ้าจะเลือกโรงแรมซัก 1 โรงแรม
อะไร
แอร์เย็นค่ะ
แอร์
ตายเนี่ยอันนี้น่าจะ 5 ดาวไหมสงกรานต์วัน
นี้เนี่ย
โรงแรม 5 ดาวชัวร์
ใช่ค่ะถ้าโรงแรมเนี่ยเขาก็จะมีช่องบาง
ครั้งเขาจะมีช่องตรงนี้ป่ะ
มันก็จะมีแอร์
ออกมา
แล้วโรงแรม
ไม่ใช่เพราะเขาว่าผู้หญิงไม่รู้ค่ะครูฟ้า
จริงๆแล้ว
อย่างแรกเลยครูฟ้าก็คือครูหญิงเนี่ยจะ
เลือกห้องห้องโรงแรมนะคะที่
ไม่สูบบุหรี่
มันเลือกได้นะ
บางครั้งเวลาที่เราเปิดเข้าไปใช่ไหมคะ
World  Wide
web.booking.com
agoda.com
traveloka.com อันนี้ที่ไทยนะนักเรียน
เวลาเราเลือกโรงแรมอย่างนี้
เราเลือกได้นะคะว่าเอาห้องที่ไม่สูบ
บุหรี่มีของสำหรับผู้หญิงสำคัญมากๆนะนัก
เรียนอันดับที่ 1 เลยห้องในโรงแรมฟ้าถ้า
ห้องนี้สูบบุหรี่ได้เวลาที่เราอินเนี่ย
เราจะเช็คอินก็ประมาณบ่าย
ประมาณบ่าย 2 โมงใช่ไหมเช็คอินนะคะคือเขา
อ่ะทำความสะอาดแล้วนะอะไรนะเช็ดพื้นถู
พื้นซักซักปลอกหมอนซักผ้าห่มซักผ้าปู
เตียง
เช็ดแต่ถ้าห้องนี้เป็นห้องที่สูบบุหรี่
ได้มันก็ยังมีกลิ่นบุหรี่ค่ะคือผู้หญิง
ไม่ชอบกลิ่นบุหรี่ถ้าได้กลิ่นบุหรี่เนี่ย
ปวดหัว
มันโอเค
ใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละก็เลยสำหรับผู้หญิงเนี่ย
เลือกอันดับ 1 เลยนะก็คือห้องต้องไม่ไม่
ใช่ห้องที่สูบบุหรี่ได้ต้องเป็นห้องที่
ไม่สูงบุหรี่นะคะแล้วครูฝากถ้าครูฟ้าจะไป
เที่ยวแล้วจะเลือกโรงแรมครูฟ้าเลือกอะไร
อ่ะที่แบบอันดับที่ 1 สำหรับครูฟ้าเลย
สะอาด
ครูฟ้าเลือกโรงแรมที่มีผีหรอคะ
นักเรียน
Do  you  know อันนี้อะไรคะ
jasper  caster เป็นใคร
แคสเปอร์แคสเปอร์ผี
เอ้า
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าจะเลือกโรงแรมที่ไม่มีผีใช่
ไหมหรือว่ามีผีไม่มีผีค่ะกูฟาร์มไม่เอาผี
แล้วคุณฟ้าจะรู้ได้ยังไงล่ะว่าเนี่ยเป็น
โรงแรม 5 ดาวเลยนะมีความรู้ได้ไง
จะรู้ได้ยังไงว่าไม่มีผี
เต้นมั้ง
แต่ครูฟ้าจองแล้วอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้าจ่ายเงิน
แล้วอ่ะ
ไม่รู้ค่ะไม่เอา
[เพลง]
ถ้าจะจองโรงแรม 1 โรงแรมจะต้องเลือกไหม
ว่าต้องมี WiFi เพราะจริงๆคุณผู้หญิง
ถ้าเที่ยวในประเทศไทยนะคะ
ผู้หญิงถ้าต้องมีมีอินเทอร์เน็ตใช่ไหม
อินเทอร์เน็ตมันจะเป็นยังไงนะโลโก้มัน
เป็นไง
ถือว่ากลับด้าน
อีกฝั่งนึงไหม
ถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยอยู่ประเทศไทย 1  2  3  4
โรงแรมเนี่ย WiFi มีไม่มีดีไม่ดี
ก็ไม่ได้นะผู้หญิงรู้สึกว่าตอนนี้ผู้หญิง
ทำงานออนไลน์ไงถ้าจะเลือกโรงแรมเนี่ย WiFi
ต้องดีค่ะ
WiFi โอเคไม่โอเคก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคะคิด
เกี่ยวกับเฟอร์นิเจอร์
พวก
นี้หรอแบบเตียงนอน
โซฟา
โคมไฟ
เตียงสวยไหมโซฟาสวยไหมไปโอเคไหมสวยไหมอัน
นี้คือฟ้าเลือกก่อน
แล้วครูฟ้าเลือกจากห้องน้ำไหม
ว่าบางครั้งเนี่ยบางคนบอกว่าห้องน้ำต้อง
มีอ่างอาบน้ำใช่ไหมครูฟ้าก็ลงไปนอนอยู่
ที่นี่
อ่างอาบน้ำ
ห้องน้ำอะไรก็ได้
ห้องน้ำอะไรก็ได้ค่ะหูฟังไม่ซีเรียส
อะไรก็ได้
เพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยก็เลือกอาจจะไม่ได้
เลือกจากห้องน้ำนะคะแต่ว่าอาจจะเลือกจะดู
ต้องดูด้วยว่าผ้าเช็ดตัวนักเรียนเนี่ยพวก
ผ้าเช็ดตัวห้องน้ำหรือว่าห้องที่เรานอนใน
โรงแรมผ้าห่มต้องสะอาดไม่ใช่เราเดินเข้า
มาในห้องหรือว่าเข้าไปในห้องน้ำแล้วก็
หยิบผ้าเช็ดตัวมาแล้วก็
มีกลิ่นอย่างนี้อันนี้ก็ไม่โอเคนะ
บางครั้งคืออันนี้เราไม่รู้หรอกนะคะนัก
เรียนในครั้งแรกถ้าเรามาโรงแรมนี้เรามา
นอนครั้งแรกเราก็ไม่รู้ใช่แต่ถ้าเรารู้
แล้วใช่ไหมบางคนก็อาจจะรู้สึกไม่เอาโรง
แรมนี้เพราะว่าผ้าเช็ดตัวหรือว่าผ้าห่ม
อย่างนี้พวกนี้ไม่สะอาดก็
โอเคนะ
เพราะว่าอย่างผู้หญิงเนี่ยถ้าจะเลือกโรง
แรมแล้วก็เตียงนอนผ้าเตียงนอนเป็นแบบใน
รูปนี้นะครูหญิงชอบไม่น่ากลัว
แต่มึงเคยแบบบางครั้งมันจะมีเตียงนอนที่
อย่างนี้ก็ครูฟ้าไม่เลือกเพราะว่าผีใช่
ไหมล่ะแต่ถ้าเตียงนอนเนี่ย
ใต้เตียง
ใต้เตียงเนี่ยโล่งๆ
มีใต้เตียงเนี่ยไม่มีใช่ไหมไม่มีใต้เตียง
แต่อันนี้เตียงนอนแล้วก็มีใต้เตียงเนี่ย
อันนี้ไม่ค่อยชอบนะเวลานอนเนี่ยนอนไม่
ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์ค่ะรู้สึกกลัว
เตียงนอนครูฟ้ามีใต้เตียงนะคะ
อันนั้นคุณอยู่บ้านไงคะครูฝากคุณอยู่บ้าน
อยู่บ้านก็โอเคแต่ถ้าโรงแรมนี้ไม่โอเคเลย
ไม่โอเคนะครูฟ้าแล้วครูฟ้าจะเลือกโรงแรม
โดยที่เช็คว่าโรงแรมเนี่ยมี
อาหารเช้า
ต้องมีอาหารเช้าเวลาครูฟ้าจะจองจองห้อง
ใช่ไหมคะจองห้องในโรงแรมเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็
ต้องเช็คว่าครูฟ้าสมมติครูฟ้านอน 1 คืน
ราคา
3,000 บาททำไม 3,000 บาทเนี่ยเขาก็จะบอก
ว่าโอเคมี wi-fi ไม่มี WiFi มี
EV จะมี
netflio มีทีวีดูได้แล้วก็มีอาหารเช้า
อาหารเช้าเนี่ยคิดว่าโรงแรมส่วนใหญ่น่าจะ
6 โมงเช้าถึง 11 โมงมีอาหารเช้า
ครูฟ้าเช็คไหมว่าเราจองโรงแรม 1 คืนเนี่ย
มีอาหารเช้าไหม
เช็คค่ะหูฟังไม่ได้ซีเรียสอาหารเช้านะแต่
ว่าครูฟ้าจะเช็คด้วยว่ามีไหมถ้าไม่มี
อาหารเช้าแต่ครูฟ้าชอบโรงแรมก็โอเคแต่ถ้า
มีอาหารเช้าด้วยก็ดีค่ะ
ดีมากชอบกินอาหารเช้าที่โรงแรม
ใช่ครูหญิงก็เหมือนกันนะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยก็
ชอบอาหารเช้าที่โรงแรมแล้วก็บางครั้ง
เนี่ยบางโรงแรมที่เราเคยไปนอนใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วเราก็รู้ว่าโรงแรมนี้เนี่ยอาหารอร่อย
คือบางทีมันอาจจะเป็นโรงแรมคุณหญิงเคยนอน
โรงแรมที่แบบ
ประมาณนะประมาณ 3 ดาว 2 หรือ 3 ดาวนี่
แหละแต่ผู้หญิงเดาว่าประมาณ 3 ละกัน 3
ดาวแล้วก็พนักงานใช่ไหมคะพนักงานก็คือผู้
ชายผู้หญิงที่ทำงานที่โรงแรมเนี่ยเป็น
สต๊าฟที่โรงแรมเนี่ยไม่ค่อยโอเคนะพูดเวลา
โอ้สวัสดีค่ะคุยโทรศัพท์เนี่ยพูดไม่ค่อย
โอเคแต่คุณหญิงเนี่ยไปนอนครั้งที่ 2
ครั้งที่ 3 นะเพราะว่าโรงแรมนี้อาหาร
อร่อยมาก
อาหารเช้าอ่ะมีนิดหน่อยนะแบบไม่ได้มี
ช้อยส์เยอะๆไม่ได้แบบเป็น International
เพราะว่ามันแค่โรงแรม 3 ดาวใช่ไหมคะแต่
อาหารเช้าส่วนใหญ่เขาเป็นอาหารก็มีอาหาร
ไทยมีอาหารฝรั่งมีสลัดใช่ไหมแต่อาหาร
อร่อยอ่ะคุณก็โอเคนะไม่เป็นไรเราเจอ
พนักงานนิดหน่อยแต่เราได้กินอาหารอร่อยไง
ถ้าอาหารอร่อยเนี่ยมันโอเคมากๆนะ
อะไรก็ตามอาจอร่อย
เพราะว่าชอบนะ
ใช่ค่ะโรงแรมแล้วอาหารเช้าอร่อยอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงก็จะบอกครูฟ้านะครูฟ้าครูหญิงไป
นอนโรงแรมเอมาอาหารอร่อยมากอ่ะอาหารเช้า
อร่อยมากครูฟ้าก็อยากไปใช่ไหมเพราะว่า
เพราะว่าผู้หญิงคิดว่าโรงแรมในประเทศไทย
นะส่วนใหญ่นะคะอาจจะซัก 70 ถึง 80% เนี่ย
ถ้านักเรียนจ่ายเงินสมมุตินอน 1 คืนอย่าง
นี้มากๆเนี่ยเขาจะรวมอาหารเช้าด้วยไงหลาย
ๆคนก็จะค่อนข้างเช็คว่าแบบเอ๊ะมีอาหาร
เช้าไหมแล้วถ้าอาหารเช้าอร่อยเนี่ยก็ดี
มากนะคะ
ซึ่งจริงๆผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าก็จะคล้ายๆกัน
นะคะเพราะว่าเราเป็นคนไทยเวลาที่เราจะจอง
โรงแรมเนี่ยเราก็จะคิดว่าไม่มีผี
ผีเนี่ยต้องเป็นสไตล์แบบคือจริงๆเป็น
สไตล์แบบนี้โอเคนะแต่ถ้าเป็นสไตล์แบบไทยๆ
อ่ะแบบที่นักเรียนชอบอ่ะเดินเข้ามาแล้ว
แบบมีรูปผู้หญิงรำไทยอันนี้คือน่ากลัวมาก
เลยนะสำหรับคนไทยผู้หญิงยังไม่เอาอีกเลย
นะ
อันนี้น่ากลัวจริงๆ
คะแล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนเนี่ยเลือก
โรงแรมจากอะไรมากที่สุดคอมเมนต์บอกเราได้
อ๋อวิดีโอนี้คุยกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ